this big election just happened in
Taiwan China of course is freaking out
because China thinks that Taiwan should
be theirs some in Taiwan are actually
flirting with the idea of declaring
independence and in the middle of all of
this the United States has made the
decision to send a bunch of American
officials to Taiwan which is the exact
thing they know will just make China
really mad the United States has to walk
this really weird ambiguous line with
Taiwan on one hand they're like required
to give them weapons and like by law
saying that they will support their
security but the other hand they don't
actually technically recognize Taiwan as
a country but the big question that
everyone's asking is would the United
States intervene if China invaded Taiwan
no one really knows so Biden sending
American officials to Taiwan right after
the election is just a way of the US
kind of saying hey we're still here we
support you and in the process they're
poking China and straining these
relations that have started to become a
little bit better if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more